jeudi dernier vous allez au domicile
d'Europe et Roca donc French rap Queen
les influenceurs accusés d'avoir
maltraité leur chien c'est ça c'est ça
vous y allez pourquoi c'est une soirée
euh faut savoir que j'ai reçu un message
sur mon compte snapchat ou il me disait
que ça lui ça fait longtemps qu'on s'est
pas vu on organise une soirée ce soir du
coup je suis allé là-bas et bah c'était
pas du tout une soirée déjà c'était pas
du tout une soirée c'était une soirée
photo donc ils aiment bien le contacter
des gens pour des photos d'accord et ce
sont c'était vos amis si vous allez à la
version
suite à ça j'ai arrêté de leur parler
car il y a une affaire de soupçon de
viol donc de drogues et de viol donc
suite à ça j'ai arrêté de leur parler
j'étais naïf j'avais 16 ans donc je suis
retourné je me suis dit peut-être qu'ils
ont changé peut-être que c'était qu'une
polémique comme voilà et je suis allée
vous entrez dans leur loft ils habitent
à Argenteuil et là vous voyez le chien
comment vous voyez le chien dans le loft
entrée il était dans quel état
il était recroquevillé il respirait fort
il pleurait oui il faut savoir il
pleurait quand ce son maître robe il
venait il se faisait pipi dessus il
avait peur donc vous avez été inquiétude
directement parce que je sais que ce
n'est pas la première fois parce que
déjà on peut voir déjà les bosses on
peut voir les
commentaires
elle avait aussi une plaie énorme comme
ça sur le corps une ici et ça se voit
que c'est de la Maxence que les gens les
aviez pas vu depuis deux ans pourquoi il
y a trop tourné
je me suis dit peut-être que ils ont
changé je suis retournée je me suis dit
pourquoi pas
à vos amis j'ai appelé tous mes amis
oui alors faut savoir qu'il y avait des
personnes là-bas à son domicile qui sont
été invités aussi comme moi il y avait
trois filles notamment une fille qui
s'appelle Lota je lui avais posé la
question de pourquoi ce chien était
capable bossé qui lui avait fait ça elle
me disait que tes robes donc le mec de
Roca son manager donc tout le temps il
le tapait apparemment c'est pour son
éducation alors qu'à un moment donné
l'éducation tu fais pas ça un chien je
suis désolé surtout un bébé de vous
occuper du chien ils vous ont autorisé à
le faire ou pas du tout alors vraiment
pas du tout alors savoir que j'ai essayé
de les nourrir devant eux parce que
j'avais acheté à manger j'ai essayé de
nourrir on m'interdissait donc du coup
il y avait même une autre fille pas pour
le chien ne nourriture pour oui c'était
ma nourriture à moi on peut comprendre
parfois que c'est avec les chiens c'est
compliqué
au moins du steak haché le chien non
mais il y avait du steak haché dans le
dans le dans mon savais les menus ah
d'accord ah d'accord très bien d'accord
excusez-moi
[Rires]
alors vous contactez tous vos amis ah
oui j'envoie des messages à tous mes
amis il faut que tu m'aides aide-moi et
le chat il est maltraité personne me
personne ne veut pas tout le monde s'en
foutait en fait à part quelques amis à
moi qui ont eu le réflexe appelle la SPA
donc du coup j'ai envoyé des messages
d'accord et vous avez vous avez alors il
était attaché à l'escalier le chien
exactement et il y avait même pas plus
de 1 m
oui non je n'ai pas le droit le chien
soi-disant bouge partout il fait chier
et pourtant alors vous dormez vous
passez la nuit là-bas pourquoi en fait
vous devez dormir chez eux ou bien non
pas du tout j'étais censé venir et
repartir une heure après ou 2h bah vous
savez le temps d'une soirée mais pour
moi c'est impossible de partir et
laisser un chien comme ça en fait
dormir là-bas pourquoi pour pour avoir
un oeil sur le chien non non pour le
sauver tout simplement de base mon plan
mon objectif c'était de me sauver avec
la nuit donc parce que faut savoir qu'il
y a la nuit vous appelez la SPA à ce que
vous dites voilà j'ai envoyé plusieurs
plusieurs
alertes sur le site pendant la nuit vous
cherchez à vous enfuir avec le chien
c'est ça donc j'ai même fait des plans à
mes amis aide-moi parce que je pensais
que la porte a été ouverte au début mais
au final non la porte la clé elle dort
avec la femme Roca
donc malheureusement j'ai pas pu j'ai
attendu le matin et j'ai attendu le
matin je suis allée en haut j'ai dit
excusez-moi je dois partir ils ont
ouvert la porte je suis parti j'ai
regardé le chien une dernière fois je
dis t'inquiète pas dans ma tête c'était
t'inquiète pas je vais pas te laisser là
je vais te sauver en gros donc du coup
faut savoir que j'ai appelé plusieurs
associations j'ai appelé la SPA mais
c'était pas ouvert avant 13h faut savoir
j'ai appelé la police les pompiers
personne n'a réagi
juste la police est arrivée quand même
elle a pu rentrer non faut savoir qu'ils
ont pas réussi à rentrer j'ai volé les
clés parce que je suis retournée là-bas
parce que comme je sais pas si vous avez
vu un peu mon Tik Tok j'ai scanné un
toit pour essayer de passer par la
fenêtre avec une amie à moi qui
s'appelle soso d'accord donc voilà je
l'avais contacté j'envoie mon petit plan
comment rentrer chez eux parce que c'est
un loft et c'est très compliqué à
rentrer dedans vous avez vu que disque
apparemment
c'est pas eux en version ils disent que
un chiot comme ça en une soirée on ne
peut pas lui faire ça on voit déjà que
les boss ça fait quand même un peu
longtemps
il vous accuse vous en fait non oui oui
m'accuse clairement moi mais là il faut
savoir qu'ils ont placé en garde à vue
déjà là ils sont passés en garde à vue
pourquoi il vous accusez dit ce que vous
êtes que vous leur voulez du mal et que
vous leur avez fait sinon je ne serai
pas aller justement alors est-ce qu'il y
a pas quand même une histoire d'amitié
brisé de jalousie alors moi j'ai pas
besoin d'être jalouse
de Roca sur votre Tik Tok il y avait des
photos avec elle devant un miroir qui
d'ailleurs sauf si je me trompe ont été
effacés vous les avez effacé d'accord
est-ce que cette proximité a pas
dégénéré finalement est-ce que quand ils
disent c'est elle qui a tapé sur le
chien est-ce qu'il y a pas madame je
vous pose la question clairement une
part de vérité il y a aucune vérité dans
ça même dans le passé vous n'avez jamais
tapé sur le aucune aucune faut savoir
que le chien c'est la première fois de
ma vie que je l'ai vu cela celui-là
Texas c'est la première fois de ma vie
que je l'ai vu parce que ça fait deux
ans que je n'ai pas vu cette personne là
pourquoi il vous accuse
le buzz écoutez c'est tout le temps la
même chose c'est tout le temps la même
chose on les accuse de quelque chose
mais vu qu'ils ont l'argent ils peuvent
pareil il y avait eu des suspicions de
viol comme je vous ai dit il y a eu 37
ans
payés
faut savoir que oui oui donc toutes ces
filles là à l'heure actuelle on a toutes
les preuves on a toutes les vidéos on a
tous les témoignages de toutes ces
filles là et toutes ces filles là ne
veulent pas en rester là au moins je le
dis je voulais pas en venir là mais quoi
qu'il arrive la défense du couple et les
catastrophique puisqu'ils sont quand
même mettre de ce chien quand on est
maître d'un chien dans les responsables
quand on retrouve un chien dans cet
état-là la moindre des choses c'est
delarter la SPA ce qu'ils n'ont pas fait
donc déjà c'est catastrophes
qui n'ont aucune valeur qui n'ont
évidemment pas la valeur du travail en
avez ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont pas la
valeur du respect on découvre ce soir
qui n'ont aucune humanité moi ces images
je peux même pas les voir elle me brise
le coeur et pardon mais faut être quel
genre de merde pour tabasser un chiot
qu'on peut pas défendre franchement
c'est dégueulasse dégueulasse et ces
gens-là ils méritent la prison ferme
c'est pas la prison avec des travaux
d'intérêt général c'est immonde de voir
ça mais la justice en ce moment même
elle ne sert à rien bon là
heureusement qu'ils sont placés en garde
à vue d'ailleurs j'ai une confrontation
avec eux à 9h du matin demain d'accord
voilà d'accord et ça on peut voir que
c'est une vidéo de Texas déjà une
semaine après l'avoir récupéré d'une
fille donc je vais pas dire son prénom
d'une abonnée à moi qui m'a envoyé un
message pour me dire qu'elle avait déjà
vu Texas donc voilà elle avait déjà la
bosse en tout cas on nous tiendrez au
courant de la suite et de l'issue de
cette affaire merci en tout cas est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose à ajouter
non je souhaite juste qu'il paye en fait
voilà qui paye le plus cher possible
donc voilà